Hey look guys my name is Jonah welcome
back to my game engine series so last
time we talked about textures I'll link
the video up there definitely make sure
that you watch that before you move on
to this video because today I'm gonna be
extending our textures to support
something called blending so at the
moment if we take a look at what we've
got in the hazel engine we loaded this
checkerboard texture which was great and
we loaded it specifically as a RGB
texture so if we take a look at the open
gel texture class that we wrote I did
mention last time that we have this kind
of channels that outputs how many
channels our actual texture contains so
what that means is basically per pixel
how many channels of color does the
texture contain in this case for this
specific checkerboard image file we had
three channels RGB and that is it we
didn't have any alpha at all and
furthermore this code at the moment can
only handle those three color channels
however what happens if we try and load
a texture that has alpha in it something
that might have a transparent background
like this channel over here well let's
go ahead and test it out so without
extra API it should be as simple as
basically just loading in and other
texture if I just stop the program here
come over to our texture that we loaded
here we'll add another texture we
helpful turn our logo texture and then
to load the texture all we need to do is
just copy this line of code and change
this to be our channel order texture and
then this actual image file that we're
loading is simply going to be channel
auger dot PNG which is the image file
that I showed earlier so now to render
something with this channel logo
let's keep our existing checkerboard
background and for this video we'll try
and actually render that channel over on
top of it so basically what should
happen and what you would expect is for
the checkerboard background to be read
it behind and then the channel logo to
be read an in front and we should still
be able to see that checkerboard
background with that kind of channel
over composited on top because it has a
lot of transparent areas of course so
we'll copy these two lines of code this
time instead of binding our texture
we'll just bind our Cherno texture and
really that should be it let's just hit
f5 and see what happens and as you can
see well this just looks really really
we
and the reason that this is happening
and we get this kind of like corrupted
look is because we're still kind of
trading that actual image data as if it
only had three channels of color which
means that the Alpha Channel is being
read as the red channel of like the next
pixel or the blue channel depending on
the ordering so it kind of just creates
this whole mess and of course something
like this could even crash it's not in
this case because RGB requires less data
than RGB a and we're actually giving it
more data so we never overflowed the
buffer or do anything like that but
that's still very far from ideal so to
fix that all we need to do is respond to
this channels input if I just put a
breakpoint here and show you guys
exactly what I mean if I launch this
program and we take a look at channels
in this case the path that we're loading
is a checkerboard background if we take
a look at the channels that it has it
has three channels RGB we already know
that that's just kind of proving my
point
if I hit f5 and we advance to the next
time that we call this function we have
the channel logo dot PNG file which has
four channels as you can see so it is in
fact RGB a so to respond to that what we
would traditionally have in a game
engine is just kind of detecting how
many channels that has and then maybe
converting into a different format
furthermore you might want to actually
force the particular format for a
texture so there's a lot of different
things that you would do in a real game
engine and but most of all you wouldn't
be loading PNG image files you would
have your own texture format so I don't
want to spend too much time here writing
stuff that's gonna work for every case
that we ever have at the end of our
engine because we'll kind of just tackle
that when we get there so what I'll do
now is just support both RGB and RGB a
because that should be pretty much
everything we need now of course we
might want like you know a one channel
texture so it may be something that's
kind of crazy ale which we could use
with opengl by just specifying you know
jail red or something like that which
would be just kind of just one texture
channel however we're not gonna talk
about that until we actually get that
because I don't think that will meet
that for a while so I'll type Jill enum
and then we have two different formats
you can say the one we using here is
called the internal format and then the
one that we're using in texture sub
image is just a format so texture sub
Imogen
here's the genome format parameter so
texture sub image this is us uploading
our actual data so what we need to
supply here is the format of our data
however this texture storage 2d is
defining how opengl is going to store
our texture this is different
alright because you could for example
upload RGB eight data but then interpret
it only as RGB that's totally fine we're
not doing that in this case they're
actually going to be the same because we
want to obviously interpret RGB a as RGB
a but just letting you guys know that
you can actually do different things
with this you could you don't have to
necessarily match these two things which
is why they are two different parameters
and we'll treat them as such so we'll
have our internal format meaning how
opengl stores it you could call this
OpenGL format or something internal
format is a pretty good term for it
though would simply check how many
channels it has so channels equals four
I'll actually expand this letting will
set the internal format to zero just to
initialize it and then what I'll do is
I'll say if channels equals four we'll
set the internal so we'll do two things
because we'll have both the internal
format and the the data formats I'll say
internal format equals 0 them also have
data format equals to 0 so definitely
can't be 0 so we'll set them over here
in this F statement so if channels is 4
then we're going to go ahead and set the
internal format to be RGB a 8 right so 8
meaning 8 bits per channel and then RGB
a being the format and then for the
format we don't need that RGB a 8
because that's the format of our data we
just simply write and this is called the
data format we just simply rise GL RGB
which is already allowed to be a because
it's the Alpha Channel version and then
we'll have a else gif channels equals 3
we'll do the same thing but of course
we'll set this to RGB 8 which is what it
was at or and RGB which is what it was
before alright so now we have this
pretty good if statement what I'll do
now at this point they should obviously
both be said they shouldn't be 0 anymore
so I'll just Chucky an egg
here to make sure that that is the case
so we'll say basically in the kernel
format and data format you should really
only need to check one of them because
of course they're both zero but doesn't
matter we'll set them both up here and
we could even like add them together
really because this will just be 0 right
if they're both 0 so we'll say if that
is the case
we'll simply write that we're trying to
load a format that isn't supported so
formats not supported okay and then that
way if we do hit that because we're
trying to load for example a texture
which with just one channel per pixel
then we can handle it and expand this
and probably revisit this by that stage
anyway ok fantastic so now we replace
this with our internal format and then
we replace GL RGB with our data format
ok beautiful so now if we hit a
breakpoint here hit f5 verify that
everything works you'll see that before
our checkerboard where we have three
channels it does go into this branch and
we actually set it to RGB which is
correct and then for our 4 channel
texture our channel logo it goes into
RGB a so now if I just resume this
program when we take a look at the
result what we should see is our shadow
texture rendering now this looks pretty
hilarious it should look like this
and furthermore that checkerboard
background should be visible behind it
because of course all of this white area
and some of these orange areas should in
fact be transparent and this is still
definitely weird and what I'll actually
do is slightly move that chair no longer
out of the way so the second time we
render this I'll actually apply a
translation to it
we'll say GLM translate GLM matte 41.0
and then GLM avec 3
so by 0.25 and negative 0.25 in the x
and y-axes respectively and then we'll
multiply that let me just make this a
little bit easier to read and then we'll
multiply this with our scale matrix so
that we get both the translation and the
scale being applied if I hit f5 when we
take a look at what that looks like
basically our channel logo should be
shifted off a little bit down and to the
right and you can see that's what we get
so this white area would really be it
really should be
parent so let's take a look at why
that's not happening and how we can make
that happen
so this has to do with blending and I
made a really good OpenGL video
specifically about the details I had
like a PowerPoint presentation I talked
about blending functions how everything
gets calculated in depth definitely
watch that video for more details
because I don't want to repeat that here
but basically what we need to do is
actually enable blending in OpenGL and
set the correct blending function
basically blending refers to how OpenGL
treats alpha and just things with alpha
in general how we get two different
colors in our congeal and we decide that
we're gonna combine this orange color
which might be slightly transparent this
case of course nothing's like
translucent it's like a hundred percent
transparent or it's just full kind of
orange we don't have that here but
regardless it refers to how we can
combine colors together and how look for
example in this case all those
transparent alpha pixels we have in our
channel logo how they should get
rendered on top of our checkerboard
background because in this case well the
checkerboard background should win out
for that specific pixel when we try and
write that into our color buffer I want
that checkerboard background to win why
because the Cherno logo on top to that
pixel is completely transparent
that's what blending is all about
definitely watch that video because if
you're not familiar with it it's really
important that you learn that and that
you weren't actually how it works
because it's gonna be super important
for this as this we're kind of moving on
with the 2d side of our engine this
stuff's gonna be very very important
otherwise all your sprites will have
absolutely no transparency and
everything will just be kind of blocks
on top of each other which will be
really weird so anyway with that in mind
how do we treat blending in our engines
so basically what we need to do is upon
initializing our renderer we don't even
have a render initialization function
yet so we'll create that will kind of
set up the kind of the kind of whole
system I guess of when we create our
renderer when the window has been
created and when we create our renderer
we have to do a whole bunch of stuff to
kind of set everything up right
specifically in this case we want to
enable blending in the future we'll want
to enable various other things like
depth testing numerous other things we
might want to retrieve the capabilities
of the actual device that we're
rendering
so this GPU that I'm rendering on let's
try and get all the info from what that
GPU actually is can it you know what
level of like anti-aliasing can you
support what level of anisotropic
filtering can support it was the largest
texture size that it can support that
kind of stuff because we need to be
aware of what the capabilities of our
end render device actually are so that
we can properly render on it and try not
to crash that's how we can kind of
support more platforms and more GPUs in
the future as well so that whole thing
and there's a lot of other things that
we need is set up as well but I'm not
gonna get into them now the point is we
need a point for us to actually
initialize how renderer and that is
exactly where we're going to set up all
the blending stuff in OpenGL so let's
take a look at how we're gonna adjust
architecture that whole thing so if I
come back to our code we know that
inside the application class we create
our window and then we kind of just
start pushing the IMU layer which of
course will already do kind of render a
code and we kick off our run loop which
renders everything so this would be a
really good place inside our application
when we actually initialize and create
this window for us to also create our
renderer and the way that we would like
to do this of course in is in a
cross-platform kind of way because
application LCVP is a cross-platform
function nothing to do with OpenGL and
also will kind of follow the pattern of
all of everything else that we've done
that is kind of render API agnostic by
just calling renderer in it right so
instead of renderer begin renderer and
renderer like what what are we doing
sandbox we had hazel renderer submits a
renderer submit right that kind of
things just render or emit in this case
to initialize it and that should be all
that we need so now we have to follow
basically the flow of everything else
that we've already done and this pattern
will be the same as it is for submit so
the first thing we'll do is make a
static function inside a renderer call
in it will go over to our source file
and we'll create that function and then
in this case the actual render command
that we used for submission for example
to draw something was read the command
draw index in that same format we'll
just type in around the command in it so
this is the initialization around the
command that we give to our renderer so
if we go over to render command and
take a look at how that set up you can
see that what we do is we simply have
inline static voids everywhere that just
call the underlying renderer API
whatever that may be
so we'll just have inline static void in
it and then s renderer API our in s
right just like that super easy so now
inside our render API we need to create
a virtual function called init set that
equal to zero of course pure virtual and
then if we go over to our OpenGL
rendering API which is our OpenGL
specific version of this class then we
simply type in virtual void emits
override right so we implemented the
function inside this class and then
hopping over to our header file we'll
take void OpenGL renderer API Ahmir so
we'll implement that function and now
we're in a place where we can call
opengl code now I've had a few people in
the comments and underscore just kind of
discuss this pattern and be like isn't
that overly complicated you're touching
like four classes here and the thing is
yeah I mean it's not as simple as if we
stopped opengl coding application or
even in renderer or even in like some
render api thing like why do we have so
many layers of abstraction why is it not
that simple the reason is that we want a
completely platform or specifically
render API agnostic way of doing all of
these things right the this kind of
renderer API initialization needs to
touch our actual render API code so in
this case we need to call GL commands
OpenGL commands we're dealing with
Vulcan we don't want to be anywhere near
this code it might not even be compiled
and it should still work and in fact
with this system it will still work what
if we're what if we've implemented
DirectX 11 or DirectX 12 on Windows and
then we're trying to compile hazel on
Mac or Linux right in that case we can't
even compile do the DirectX files files
that include DirectX header files for
example we can't compile them because
those just will not be available on
Linux or a Mac or any other platform
that doesn't support DirectX so how do
we write this in a way that is
completely agnostic and this is one of
the ways that you can do that by having
this system where even though it does
kind of cause some interruption
basically if you take a look at what's
actually happening we're calling
rendering it that's that's calling a
render command in it and then render
command in it is simply calling OpenGL
renderer API in it
so it's kind of like three levels it's
not that bad and the reason that we have
that ran the command thing for example
is first of all so that we can have like
so that we can call these things
statically without a fight without
actually having to like I guess realize
a certain interface or anything like
that we can just do it statically and
also because in the future we're gonna
have this render a run on a different
thread and for that to work we need to
be able to send commands into a render
command queue and that kind of stuff by
the way has already been done in the
Hazelden branch which you can get access
to by helping to spoil serious patient
Oakland for session the chair no huge
thank you as always to all patrons that
make this series possible so if you're
interested in how this architecture will
actually come to be in the future why
it's like this jumping ahead and taking
a look at the hazel developer branch is
definitely the best way to do that so
back in our code here now that we are in
a place where we can actually call
OpenGL commands we're going to go ahead
and type in GL enable GL blend okay so
we're enabling blending that myself is
not gonna do much because the default
blend function is still not gonna work
out really well so what we need to do is
actually set up the blend function that
we want and again my OpenGL video which
are links describes this stuff in depth
so if you're more interested in why this
is the way that it is and what how this
function gets evaluated I've got like
maths and stuff in that video that
actually covers this so check out that
video so our plan function that we want
which is kind of our typical blend
function is GL sauce alpha for the sauce
factor and ngl 1 - sauce alpha for our
destination factor so now that we've
enabled blending and set up a blend
function we should just be able to call
this init function and the way that we
of course do that is through application
and renderer in it we should just be
able to call that code at the beginning
of initializing our renderer and it
should just work so if we just run our
engine right now we should see hopefully
everything blending correctly and as you
can see we do that is so much better
this is exactly the result that we kind
of expect what we're gonna do now is
just move this channelago back into its
original place so I'll just quickly jump
into sandbox app LCVP and then just
basically get rid of this whole track
GLM translate line and so that we're
just scaling it up like we were before
and that's it let's hit a five again and
we'll see that in action okay and as you
can see we've got that Renault logo on
that checkerboard background
everything's blending correctly and it
looks really good so that is blending
absolutely necessary for any kind of
graphics rendering so I'm glad that
we've finally got that in hazel now if
you did catch my video about hazel and
2d or 3d where it's exactly going I'll
link it up there in case you missed it
as you know we are going to be
continuing on with 2d rendering in hazel
because that's what all of you guys
chose even though it was very very close
of course and so this is especially
important for that so I'm glad that
we're kind of jamming this in and just
to give you an idea where we're going
we're going to be working towards more
2d rendering again if you are interested
in 3d and you're not very happy with the
outcome of the poll I did try and make
it as fair as possible I had a real poll
we had like over 4,000 people which is
quite a lot and it did tip slightly
towards 2d so that's why I chose 2d just
because you guys wanted it but if you're
still a little bit unhappy with that you
want to see nice beautiful 3d rendering
I will be continuing to post kind of dev
logs from that hazel development branch
which is available for patrons I'll
continue to post a blog specifically
about that and show off what I'm working
on because I will still continue
building up that 3d renderer in hazel in
the development branch and keep pushing
that out to patrons and that will of
course form the basis for these kind of
game engine series videos when we
eventually finish duty and move on with
free so it's kind of cool because on
these videos we'll be developing to Lee
and you can kind of see all that and
I'll kind of teach that properly but
then the hazel development branch will
contain all the 3d code which is a way
for me to almost build 2d and 3d at the
same time and then as a reward for
helping to support the series you can
get access to that wall that lovely 3d
code I will see you guys next time
goodbye
you
[Music]